e
okay being one o'clock we'll open up the
work session on House Bill
1560 oh so you haven't got your watch on
I got my I got my Apple time right here
okay I I know oh little little bit slow
anyway since we have some handouts would
you you want to go over what what we've
data so I passed out a little packet of
of handouts uh that the committee can
use as you work through this bill the
first is just the uh RSA 19839
so this outlines all of the uses the
current statutory uses of the education
trust fund as well as all the statutory
sources of revenue for the education
trust fund so you'll see all of that
there for your
reference the next document is dated
January
18th uh which is through essentially
December a little into January of what
we know for the education trust fund
where we are currently so
um looking at the gray shaded out column
you'll see fiscal 23 has been audited
and is final so this came right from the
state's audited AER for fiscal 203 with
from the revenue Focus through 6 months
of the fiscal year uh revenues in the
education trust fund were down $2.8
million so that adjustments taken into
account down below is all the
Appropriations so you'll see all the
lines that say house bill one or House
Bill two that's what was in the budget
the lines that say warrants are
estimated uh
additional uh funding that will be
needed above what was budgeted so in
total all of those Nega are
Appropriations I I will point out one
audity on line 31 the education Freedom
accounts you may
recall uh as part of a house bill 2
amendment that was done there was a $10
million a year um reduction to the
education Freedom accounts appropriation
so that's why it's presented there as a
positive so House Bill one had $29.8
million minus that $10 million reduction
and then ultimately it's that ended up
being about $4.4 million short what we
think it's it's going to be for 23 so it
got complicated with the education
Freedom accounts just because of the way
that was included in the budget um all
told uh for this fiscal year what we're
projecting now as for what we know the
education trust fund will have about a
43.4 million surplus on line 49 you see
that at the end of the year which would
$61.60 4 million
carried into 25 same thing if you follow
everything down that's going out of ways
now you're talking next fiscal year we
could potentially have a $253 million
bonum and we're in FY 2025 now uh we're
in fiscal 24 right now this is yeah we
fiscal 24 will end June 30 2024 and then
fiscal 25 will pick up yeah
y
if no qu or I think representative Heath
may have a question just I have a
question about the um well the episodic
treatment uh
placements episode of treatment
million um and we have no basis for how
much that could
be because this is the first year that
we've done this so so already it's that
much so if you recall the $9.2 million
was for the bium the entire bium yeah uh
it was the decision
of I can't remember if it happened in
this committee or in the Senate I think
it was the Senate uh decided to
essentially appropriate all that and
have it be a charge to 23 and carry into
24 and 25 for the Department to spend so
that 9.2 was our estimate to cover this
whole bium it's just presented in fiscal
23 here but it will be spent in 24 and
25 okay but that's an open warrant so we
that is an open warrant we don't know
what it we won't know until you know
we'll get reporting at the end of the
fiscal year maybe the department has
information on that and court ordered
placements year-to date uh but whatever
they do need for either of those
programs they don't need any legislative
intervention they can draw a warrant to
pay whatever those total costs are can I
go on one more question when sure so
once upon a time when I worked at the
department um court ordered placements
would be taken out of catastrophic Aid
if we had if we had covered all the
payments they used they emptied out the
catastrophic aid for that does that ever
happen anymore do you know I think if
anything it goes the other way I think
if there's any unexpended court ordered
placements it remains in special it
doesn't lapse back to the education
trust fund it's dedicated to that yeah
and I don't think that occurred I think
I think they had to draw a warrant for
court order placements last year I'd
have to double check on that but but no
the the what you appropriate for the
special education the former
catastrophic Aid that goes just to those
you so are you good with that sheet I
can show you bring to the next one so
the next is an excerpt from this year is
AER the annual comprehensive financial
report uh so it says page 150 in the top
Corner this is a 10-year summary of the
education trust f
so you can see since 2014 I'm just going
to jump right down to the bottom the
second to last row uh from 2014 to
2023 for the first four years of this
10year span the general fund was
actually transferring to the education
trust fund because the education trust
fund was uh in the negative since 2018
you'll see that there has been a surplus
carried in the education trust fund and
it's grown uh the
$61.61 to end fiscal 23
that's uh is the starting point from the
previous document that we just went over
so this illustrates I think what we
heard testimony this morning about how
the education trust fund used to require
the general fund intervention now it's
kind of gone the other
way so that's just a reference document
for the committee and then lastly it's
not necessarily directly related to this
bill uh but this is the the document
representative wer referred to this
morning and I included that here as well
as emailed it to the entire Committee
reference so this gets to the discussion
you were having before we started is is
it is this a a correct assumption or is
it is it just adequacy that we're
talking about the court overs yeah I
think you're right Mr chair and I think
you know a great person to answer that
question might be the someone from the
Attorney General's office who actually
participated in the lawsuit because they
they will have a clear understand
understanding of what the order actually
says um given that they were present
when those arguments were made so
hopefully somebody's got to know
somewhere yeah yeah and I I I don't
believe that this is a minor point I
think we really do need to understand
what the order said right and I um you
know the difference between an average
per pupil and an adequate per pupil is a
big gap and I think we all need to have
a a good grasp of what the court is
actually saying and what our
responsibility and duty is to fulfill
Mr chairman would you like to make a
one well let's let's educate ourselves
let's find
out yes could I just add that I think
behind
Cornell's issue
the burden on the local
taxpayers paid played a big role in that
event um and even though New Hampshire
does spend about $3 billion dollar a
year on education 80% of that money
comes from Lo local property taxpayers
not the state so I think the intent and
again I think um representative Parkin
Phillips is exactly correct we should
hear from an expert on this because I I
I believe that the whole issue is around
um relieving the burden that local
property taxpayers pay with regard to
public education and I spoke a little
bit about special education um we've
been um I have a bill um that I don't
know if it'll come here or not it's it's
actually was just heard in education
about um having a commission to look at
the cost behind special education and
the um Fair School Fair funding did an
analysis it's just it's remarkable the
burden that our local taxpayers are
paying to make school districts whole um
so I think behind conell is really the
the issue of the adequacy per a student
and the the role that the state plays in
delivering that but I think again we
should hear from an expert
well I'm going to say I think
we're R off of the point yes I agree
because this this bill has nothing to do
with adequacy this bill has to do with
education trust fund at the end of the
year with all
allocations anything that's unallocated
goes into the general fund it doesn't
really talk about adequacy or anything
else and I I think as a committee we got
to get that answer but I don't think it
pertains to this particular
bill so does anybody have any comments
about this particular bill yeah so if I
could follow up with that
um representative tersi this morning
made a really good point if we know that
the education subcommittee is currently
meeting and discussing these important
funding issues uh which you are sir a
part of that I'm enjoy every minute of
it um you know it does seem uh like
there are a lot of unknowns um currently
before us as the legislature not only
not only in terms of you know what this
specific question before us about you
know whether or not we decide to empty
the education Trum trust fund at the end
of the year but also you know what are
our responsibilities F filling the
education trust fund and allocating the
education trust fund so um it is a
bigger piece of the context it is a
bigger piece within the context that is
being discussed in in other parts of
this um legislative body so you know
what is the harm of either including
this as part of that discussion or in
waiting to see how that discussion
unfolds to see you know what is a
responsible
um direction for us to take on this
issue I mean for instance if the
subcommittee determines that I mean
hypothetically that they're going to go
with these opportunity grants um is it
irresponsible to empty the education
trust fund when we know if that were to
pass that you know having that you know
capital reserve within the education
trust fund might be supportive is it is
it too early to make a
call to empty this without knowing the
answer to that good work that's my
question I I'll I'll answer your
question on I'm standing on real firm
sand
um if that if that was to come to be
then that would be
allocated and it could not be turned
into the general fund it would basically
earmark that amount of money in the
educational trust fund that will not
transfer out that's my understanding of
of what this is trying to
say
so is that a correct assumption yes but
this this allows the first year of the
of the bium which we're in to use that
money if it's needed but at the end of
this first year of the bium we're going
to put it into the to the general fund
because by that time we may have
identified
shortcomings elsewhere in some other
department that we don't want to have
this money tied to say you can't use it
because this education trust fund by the
same token if we had a great
extraordinary need in the education
trust fund even if we moved it to the
general fund we would still use it if it
needed and go back and get it as as we
have in the past we've always used money
out of the general fund for education
but when you tie a fund up like we
couldn't use Highway fund even if there
was a surplus even if we needed it
somewhere else we couldn't use it
because of the Constitution
so it's not a problem if there's an
extraordinary need in education even if
we move this money out of the education
trust fund where it now sits unusable
for the majority of our needs which is a
wrong way to do it when you're trying to
look at a whole budget which this
committee does
comment yes um I just think this is a
good time to do this right now uh with
everything we have going on but I do
want to say that back in
2008 our country and our state of New
Hampshire went through a horrible
recession um and I I was working at the
department at that time and I remember
sitting in the governor's office with
the governor and we didn't know what to
do um we did not have $200 million in
the general fund we were not not able to
meet the adequacy so what we had to do
we luckily we had back then ARA money
that we were able that had fell in the
category of General use that we were
able to take and put to make the
adequacy whole so there has been a time
when the general fund was
unable and I I think we all can remember
days when we were not in a position we
are and this is thank God we're here I
mean how many states aren't here um
we're in a position where right now we
have a cushion we know that we've got
court cases going on we have all these
different things going on with regard to
education we know we we need to do
better with our special ed um uh
representative lad had the bill where we
we um last year that would be a p we'd
pay a higher percentage which
unfortunately never made it through
through the budget process but there are
a lot of issues out there and the more
we study them I think we recognize the
needs that we have and I just think this
is presumptuous to make this move at
this point in time now if you wanted to
change this into a commission or send it
to the commission on education funding I
think that would be fine that would be
my
recommendation
yes thank you Mr
chair I think we all agree obviously
that U you know education needs to be
funded appropriately and I think we've
done a very solid job of that this
budget year the increase again was U
rather unprecedented so we know that the
funds that are needed right now for
Education we've done as good of a job as
we could while looking at the overall
budget all this bill will do is that it
said if we still have a surplus we do
have to increase the flexibility of you
know using those funds for the greatest
State needs which may not be in
education at the time so we'll move it
back to general fund it just sounds
prudent to me to say yes we will
increase that flexibility I fully
acknowledge that contingencies may occur
where things may change the need of the
funds but first again as it was already
said this bill would not prevent those
funds from being year marked and
therefore not transferred and second as
the handouts
show whenever the education trust fund
needs money The General fund fills it up
it's just one of those bills where I
think it would be prudent to state that
we intend to make the budget more
flexible by relabeling these funds as
general fund with a full understanding
that that will not affect education
funding nor it will prevent us from
doing anything meaningful I respect that
not everybody's on the same side but
this
okay anybody want to take any action at
time I'd like I'd like to make a motion
to uh recommend OTP
okay all right motion made in second to
OTP Mr chair yes um I was not under the
impression we were executing this bill
today um we don't exec bills we have
making a recommendation today um but
apparently everyone else is on that plan
well it was it's published as a work
session and in work sessions we can make
recommendations to full
Finance that's what we
do comment well I just said um
representative Murray is not here
because of the snow right obviously and
I am seeing here and I'm sure that
that's why representative buo is not
here so um the two of them I'm sure
would have one or to weigh in on this
I'm sitting here sort of in their stad
but um I'm sure they would like to weigh
in on it so if it could be postpone
until they could be here that would be
appreciated thank you the speaker wants
F
have
Finance would you entertain a motion to
move it to the educate the school
funding commission the committee that
we're working on got a motion we got a
first so so so so the motion is to
recommend a full Finance OTP on 1560 all
those in favor all
one two three four five
opposed I don't think you can
vote
but I appreciate it so I will so I will
record it as uh just a 52 because we
don't we are not an official replacement
sorry I'm just trying to no that's okay
that's the it has to be approved by the
speaker
understood yep
so anything else I'm I I see you're very
happy with this Mr chair I just would
like to acknowledge that we heard the
bill this morning and that it was
referred to our committee this afternoon
and now with several of our members not
here there was a a recommendation vote
taken which I feel doesn't accurately
reflect the full body's probably
intention about how the bill was
presented today and I just like to make
note for the record fully noted if they
were both here the vote would would be
54 so sure but I also agree that
probably more questions and answers
could have been entertained with Minds
who are fully um involved in this
particular issue and that we may have
had a more robust discussion well we
will have a robust discussion on
Thursday afternoon if it's exact at that
time so everybody can make their
appointments I guess we've concluded for
the this work session is complete thank
you
two